EMILY COMPAGNO, "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
MORE RIOTING IN PORTLAND AS
ANTIFA BARRICADED DOORS TO COURT
HOUSES THAT TAXPAYERS BUILT AND
THEN SET THE STRUCTURES ON FIRE.
OR AS A MEDIA DESCRIBES IT,
NOTHING SPECIAL.
YEAH, IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
THIS ON THE NEWS, GOOD LUCK.
IT’S TOUGH AWAY BEHIND SLABS OF
MARY TRUMP’S BITTER
PSYCHOANALYSIS.
BUT THEY COVER WITH THE SAME
THING.
THE RESPONSE TO RIOTS IS WORSE
THAN THE RIOTS THEMSELVES.
AT CNN, APOLOGIST FOR WRITING
CALLED RIGHT WING COVERAGE A
GROSS EXAGGERATION.
>> THERE ARE REAL PROBLEMS, AND
IT IS MADE UP ON FOX NEWS LIKE
IT IS THIS RAGING FIRE OUT OF
CONTROL, AND THAT IS A GROSS
EXAGGERATION.
IT JUST IS.
IT’S A GROSS EXAGGERATION.
>> Greg: THAT SHOULD BE THE
NAME OF HIS SHOW.
BUT IT’S NOTHING NEW, REMEMBER
CNN MOCKING THE RISE IN VIOLENT
CRIME.
>> DEMOCRATIC CITIES ARE IN
CHAOS RIGHT NOW, IS THIS WHAT
YOU WANT FROM JOE BIDEN?
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE YOUR
COUNTRY AWAY, AND THE STATUES.
>> CRIME IS ON THE RISE AS THEY
POLICE.
>> IT’S SO BAD, DEFUNDING POLICE
>> Greg: WOW, BEAVIS AND
BUTTHEAD.
I GUESS TO AN IDIOT, THAT IS
FUNNY, BUT REMEMBER THAT IT IS
THE CRIMES THAT THEY MOCK THAT
BRING THE POLICE IN TO STOP IT
WHICH INCREASES THE CHANCES FOR
ENCOUNTERS THAT CAN GO WRONG.
BUT DISMISSING VIOLENCE IN FAVOR
OF MOCKING THAT CONCERN SAVE
THEM FROM EXAMINING THEIR OWN
ROLE IN PROTECTING THE MOB AND
STOKING VIOLENCE.
OH, YES, I DON’T CONDONE
VIOLENCE THEY PLEA UNLESS I
AGREE WITH THE VIOLENCE.
>> AND PLEASE, SHOW ME WHERE IT
SAYS THAT PROTESTERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE POLITE AND
PEACEFUL, BUT I ARGUE TO YOU
TONIGHT, ALL PUNCHES ARE NOT
EQUAL, MORALLY IN THE EYES OF
THE LAW, YES.
FIGHTING HATE IS RIGHT, AND IN A
CLASS BETWEEN HATE AND THOSE WHO
OPPOSE IT, THOSE WHO OPPOSE IT
ARE ON THE SIDE OF RIGHT.
>> Greg: SO WHY THIS PATHETIC
APPEASEMENT?
WELL, THEY ARE PETTY.
IF THEY WOULD DEFEND LAW AND
ORDER, THE POLICE, OR EVEN YEARS
THE CITIZENS, THAT PUTS THEM ON
THE SAME SIDE AS TRUMP.
THEY WOULD RATHER JUMP INTO BED
WITH VIOLENCE DONE.
CNN BENDING OVER BACKWARDS TO
HIDE THE CRIMES BEHIND THIS
MEDIA CRITICISM.
CLAIMING THAT COVERING THE
VIOLENCE IS MEANT TO SMEARING
MOVEMENT AND CONDEMNING MAYHEM
HAS TO BE RACIST.
NO, WE SAY, WE ARE JUST LOOKING
AT WHAT IS HAPPENING TO A
COUNTRY THAT WE CLEARLY LOVE AND
ARE WORRIED SICK ABOUT IT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY SCARED, BUT GO
ON AND LAUGH, AND THEN CALL 911
WHEN THIS COMES TO YOUR HOUSE.
SO I WANT TO PLAY THIS TAPE FROM
THE PORTLAND POLICE UNION, AND
THEN I WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION.
LET’S GO.
>> ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS HAVE
CONDONE THE DESTRUCTION OF OUR
CITY.
THEY HAVE PLACED THEIR POLITICAL
AGENDAS AHEAD OF THE SAFETY OF
ALL OF US.
THIS MUST STOP.
>> Greg: SO, JUAN, WHAT DO YOU
THINK LOCAL OFFICIALS NEED TO BE
DOING NOW?
>> WELL, LOCAL OFFICIALS NEED TO
DEAL WITH LOCAL PROBLEMS, GREG.
THAT’S THE POINT HERE.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT TWO
VIDEOS, I DON’T KNOW IF WE HAVE
THEM, BUT ONE IS OF CHRIS DAVID
WHO WAS A VETERAN OF THE NAVY,
HE APPEARS BEFORE THESE
UNIDENTIFIED FEDERAL GROUPS, AND
HE IS WEARING A NAVY T-SHIRT, HE
HAS A BACKPACK ON HIS BACK THAT
SAYS NAVY, HE JUST WANTS TO TALK
AND THEY BEGIN BEATING AND
GASSING THE MAN.
HOW ABOUT A SECOND VIDEO?
LIST OF ANOTHER MAN WHO IS IN
THE VIDEO WALKING AWAY WHEN AN
UNMARKED CAR SHOWS UP, GRABS
HIM, AND CAMOUFLAGE, THROWING
HIM IN AN UNMARKED CAR, AND HE
LATER SAYS THEY JUST RELEASED
HIM.
HE IS NEVER CHARGED WITH
ANYTHING.
HE DOESN’T KNOW WHO THEY WERE OR
WHAT HAPPENED.
SO INCIDENTS LIKE THOSE ARE WHY
THEY HAVE THE OREGON
ATTORNEY GENERAL SUING HOMELAND
SECURITY.
IT’S WHY THE ACLU IS FILING
LAWSUITS, AND THESE SUITS, THEY
ARGUE THAT LOCAL MATTER SHOULD
BE HANDLED BY LOCAL AUTHORITIES,
AND THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES, THE
MAYOR, THE GOVERNOR, BOTH
SENATORS WANT TRUMP’S TROOPS OFF
THE STREET.
WHAT THEY SAY, AND HERE IS TED
WHEELER, HE SAYS THE FEDS ARE
PROVOKING VIOLENCE, ESCALATING
THE VANDALISM.
SAYING THIS IS POLITICAL THEATER
STAGED BY TRUMP TO DIVIDE A
COUNTRY AND CREATE A CAMPAIGN
ISSUE WHERE HE CAN PLAY LAW AND
ORDER HERO.
BUT IT IS AN ABUSE OF FEDERAL
POWER.
AND I HEAR CONSERVATIVE SAY,
HEY, WHAT ABOUT STATES RIGHTS?
NOTHING THIS TIME.
SO I WOULD JUST ASK EVERYONE,
WHAT ARE TACTICAL UNITS,
TACTICAL UNITS FROM BORDER
PATROL AND IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS DOING IN THE STREETS OF
PORTLAND, OREGON?
THAT IS AN ABUSE OF POWER.
>> Greg: BECAUSE ANARCHY MEANS
NO ONE IS SAFE AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO RESERVE ORDER.
THAT’S WHAT IT IS THEREFORE.
EMILY, AND SEATTLE 12 COPS WERE
INJURED.
THERE WAS RIOTS AND LOOTING.
IF WE STOP THAT, WE ARE INVADING
A LOCAL PROBLEM ACCORDING TO
JUAN, RIGHT?
>> Emily: I DISAGREE,
RESPECTFULLY WHAT WE ARE SEEING
ON THE STREETS, THOSE ARE
FEDERAL CRIMES.
THROWING EXPLOSIVES FALLS UNDER
TITLE 18.
THAT IS A FEDERAL CRIME AND
RESERVES A FEDERAL RESPONSE,
BECAUSE A LOCAL LEADERSHIP IS
NOT DOING ANYTHING.
AND THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING THAT
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT
ITS CITIZENS.
THE FULL OUT ATTACKS ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CITIES, THAT
IS FOOTAGE WE ARE LOOKING AT.
THAT IS UNDENIABLE.
AND FOR THESE FECKLESS
INVERTEBRATE GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS TO PIVOT TO THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT AND SAY THAT IT IS A
FEDERAL OVERREACH WHEN THEY ARE
FAILING THEIR COMMUNITY IS
ABSOLUTELY LUDICROUS.
WE ARE WATCHING A WAR ON THE
STREETS.
WE ARE WATCHING OFFICERS BEING
KILLED, AND I AM ONE OF THOSE
SEATTLE RESIDENTS WHO IS
WATCHING THE CITY BEING
DESTROYED ALONGSIDE LIVELIHOODS
WHILE MAYOR DURKAN AND
MAYOR WHEELER PLAY FDIC WITH THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, OR THEIR
INSULAR SOCIALIST MERRY BAN OF
PILGRIMS, BECAUSE THEY JUST WANT
TO GET REELECTED OR ANSWER TO
THEIR SMALL ELECTORAL’S.
I HAVE TO POINT OUT THAT
REGARDLESS HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
THIS PRESIDENT OR THIS
ADMINISTRATION, WE NEED HELP.
THESE CITIES ARE BEING OVERRUN
BY ORGANIZED ANARCHISTS WHILE
HOMELESS AND DRUG ADDICTS ARE
ALLOWED TO FESTER IN THESE "SAFE
CITY’S."
ALL OF THE POLITICIZED ASIAN
NEEDS TO BE PUT ASIDE, BECAUSE
WE NEED HELP AND IT IS NOT
COMING FROM LOCAL LEADERSHIP.
>> Greg: JESSE, YOU KNOW THAT
THE LOCAL LEADERSHIP IS
DESPERATE IF THEY ARE TRYING TO
LINK THEIR INCOMPETENCE TO
TRUMP, THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS HIS
FAULT.
>> YES, FEDERAL AGENTS ARE THERE
TO PROTECT FEDERAL PROPERTY, AND
THEY ARE NOT TRUMP’S TROOPERS,
THEY ARE CALLED FEDERAL
PROTECTIVE SERVICE.
THEY ARE THERE TO PROTECT
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY ARE FROM HOMELAND SECURITY,
AND THE COURTHOUSE OF THE
FEDERAL DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
PORTLAND, AND IT HAS BEEN
VANDALIZED.
THEY HAVE HAD WINDOWS BROKEN,
THEY HAVE HAD BULLET PROOF DOORS
SMASHED WITH HAMMERS, THE
ANARCHISTS ARE TRYING TO TAKE
OVER A FEDERAL BUILDING SO THAT
THEY ARE THERE TO PROTECT THE
FEDERAL BUILDING AND WHEN THE
AGENTS ARE THERE TO PROTECT
FEDERAL PROPERTY, THEY HAVE HAD
LASERS POINTED INTO THEIR EYES
AND THEY HAVE HAD COMMERCIAL
GRADE FIREWORKS SHOT AT THEM.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO HIT PEOPLE
WITH VEHICLES, AND WHEN YOU COME
IN AND TAKE SOMEONE AWAY IN A
VAN, THAT IS A TRADITIONAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT DE-ESCALATION
TACTICS.
BECAUSE WHEN SOMEONE ASSAULTS A
FEDERAL AGENT OR COMMITS A CRIME
ON FEDERAL PROPERTY, THEY NEED
TO BE ARRESTED.
NOW, THEY ARE TWO WAYS OF DOING
THAT.
YOU CAN SEND IN A BUNCH OF
FEDERAL AGENTS INTO THE MIDDLE
OF A CROWD OF 100 ANARCHISTS AND
TRY TO ARREST AN INDIVIDUAL, OR
YOU CAN ISOLATE THEM LATER WHEN
THEY ARE MORE ALONE AND MAKE AN
ARREST.
THAT’S HOW GOOD POLICING IS DONE
DONE.
IT’S ALSO FUNNY TO HEAR THE LEFT
COMPLAIN ABOUT TRUMP SENDING
FEDERAL AGENTS ANYWHERE AFTER
THEY SEND FEDERAL AGENTS INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT’S LITERALLY WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY WERE OKAY WITH THAT, BUT
FEDERAL AGENTS IN PORTLAND.
>> Greg: YES, NOT JUST TO
PROTECT CITIZENS, BUT YOU CAN GO
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO IT IS A LOOK AT, OUR SIN AND
VIOLENCE IS A LOCAL PROBLEM, BUT
POLICE BRUTALITY IS A NATIONAL
OR GLOBAL CONCERN.
>> Dagen: RIGHT, EXACTLY.
IMAGINE BEING SO UNSWERVINGLY
STEADFAST ANTI-TRUMP THAT YOU
ARE PRO-CRIME.
THAT VIOLENCE AND LOOTING GET A
DOUBLE THUMBS UP FROM THE CLOWNS
OF SOME OF THESE TV NETWORKS AND
THEIR BROTHER AND RUNNING IN THE
STATES PUMP, AND CITIES IN SOME
OF THESE AREAS, BUT IT IS AN
ABOMINATION TO TALK ABOUT
ENFORCING THE LAW AND FIGHTING
CRIME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTUALLY
STANDING UP FOR HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY, IT IS TO
TAKE CARE THAT THE LAWS BE
FAITHFULLY EXECUTED.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, THESE LOSERS
IN PLACES LIKE, NO DISRESPECT,
EMILY, AND WASHINGTON AND OREGON
ARE DOING, THEY ARE TURNING
THEIR BACK ON OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTY, BECAUSE IT IS IN THE TENTH
AMENDMENT THAT THE STATES HAVE
THE RIGHT TO STAND UP FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE CITIZENS AND
ACTUAL DUTY TO DO THAT.
IT’S PERFECTLY OKAY IF FEDERAL
CRIMES ARE BEING COMMITTED
WHETHER IT IS DRUG CRIMES, OR
THE FED CAN PROVE A RACKETEERING
ENTERPRISE TO GO IN WITH NO
INVITATION AND NO INFORMATION.
BUT I PUSH BACK ON ONE THING,
THOSE TWO ARE NOT BEAVIS AND
BUTTHEAD.
THAT IS AN INSULT TO MIKE JUDGE
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
I APOLOGIZE TO MIKE JUDGE.
>> Juan: LET ME QUICKLY THROW
THIS IN THERE THAT I THINK LOCAL
VOTERS UNDER THAT TENTH
AMENDMENT HAVE A RIGHT TO HOLD
LOCAL OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE IF
THEY THINK THEY ARE NOT DOING A
GOOD JOB.
AND THOSE LOCAL OFFICIALS WANT
TO GET REELECTED.
SO THEY ARE ANSWERING TO THEIR
LOCAL CONSTITUENTS.
AND ONE OTHER POINT, YOU KNOW
WHAT, POLICE BRUTALITY AGAINST
BLACK PEOPLE AS A NATIONAL
PROBLEM.
THAT’S WHY IT GOT NATIONAL